amor libre poliamor relaciones que no se
basan en la exclusividad sino que
integran a otras personas cada día
entonces van ganando más terreno y crean
una red efectiva donde el amor se
multiplica y el vínculo de la pareja
pierde la jerarquía que instauró el
llamado amor romántico desde hace
décadas existe este amor libre y quienes
practican el poliamor cuestionen la
exclusividad y la jerarquía como los
únicos pilares de este sentimiento pero
además el amor romántico no es el único
hay como ya lo dijimos otras formas de
vivirlo y para esto hablaremos con
nuestra invitada del día la saludó ella
es alba a centauri psicóloga educadora
sexual y también creadora de arroba poli
activismo gracias entonces alva por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 le pregunto qué ha cambiado
actualmente con el san valentín desde su
opinión y que otras maneras hay de vivir
el amor fuera de lo romántico
hola raúl muchas gracias por la
invitación pues pensemos en el amor que
tenían quizá nuestros abuelos y abuelas
hace apenas un par de generaciones yo
creo que en el amor actual ha cambiado
que tenemos unas expectativas mucho más
altas sobre lo que la pareja debe
proveernos en términos de cubrir
nuestras necesidades
quizá antes no se le pedía a una pareja
que tuviera una visión unos valores del
mundo similares y sí que pudiéramos
conformar una familia con ella entonces
hoy en día creo que son muchas más las
necesidades interpersonales y sociales
que esperamos que cubra la relación de
pareja quizá precisamente porque cada
vez vivimos en un mundo más
individualista en donde esa es nuestra
única esperanza de compañía social
hablemos entonces de esos dos tipos de
relaciones el poliamor también la
monogamia en estos tiempos es difícil
realmente mantener una pareja como
nuestros abuelos o nuestros papás por
toda la vida jamás doctora le pregunto
por qué me causa curiosidad cómo manejar
también digamos si uno abre una relación
los celos las inseguridades tiene que
estar uno como preparado para poder dar
ese paso
bueno yo pensaría que no es que estos
modelos o estos tipos de estructuras de
relación sean precisamente nuevos sino
que hoy en día tenemos más visibilidad y
además
la monogamia ha tomado más terreno se
considera el modelo hegemónico o
imperante en la mayoría de culturas
alrededor de la tierra entonces yo
pienso que es importante entender las
relaciones poliamor osas otros tipos de
la monogamia consensuada como algo que
ha estado siempre presente y que las
habilidades para relacionarnos de esta
forma ya las tenemos en muchos contextos
en los que no solamente la familia
nuclear mamá y papá son quienes crían
por ejemplo en en el tema de los celos
pues bueno como se pueden imaginar
requiere una gran capacidad de
regulación o de gestión que está ahora
más de moda este término emocional en
donde tengamos la capacidad tanto de
entender como de comunicar nuestras
emociones sin ser violentos o agresivos
digamos que cualquier persona pueda lo
mejor practicar el poliamor o el
poliamor no es para todo el mundo
yo creo que todas las personas queremos
a más de alguien en nuestras vidas
cierto la parte distinta en el poliamor
quizá es que como tú bien decías al
inicio de la entrevista se le da
prioridad al amor de pareja pero si
somos capaces de tener varias amistades
y no ponernos celosas entre entre ellas
o somos capaces de querer a nuestros
varios hermanos y hermanas porque no
podríamos querer a varias parejas la
mayoría de personas tenemos una
capacidad afectiva múltiple y donde
ponemos este peso de la exclusividad es
únicamente en el amor romántico en el
amor de pareja ahí podemos empezar a
cuestionar por qué es este amor el que
requiere exclusividad qué tiene de
especial que le requiera ser exclusivo a
diferencia del amor familiar o del amor
de la amistad
si además doctora yo creo que eso
también pues tiene que ver como con la
pareja cómo se sientan cómodos ellos y
la decisión de cada quien y decir pues
puedo pues lidiar con un poliamor o
simplemente me quedo en una relación de
pareja tradicional como le decíamos el
amor romántico pero ahora le pregunté
entonces en nuestros tiempos hablando
nuevamente de este día de san valentín
cuáles son todos los estereotipos que
han cambiado festejar este día entrega
de rosas ya no es tan tradicional que ha
cambiado hoy en el 2022 hace no sé diez
años atrás 20 años atrás
bueno primero me gustaría dejar dicho
que la celebración de san valentín tal y
como la conocemos hoy en día es
relativamente reciente
entonces pues no es más interesante
quizás como esto empezó a surgir a cómo
ha cambiado en los últimos 20 o 30 años
porque quizá no es tanto como como nos
imaginaríamos yo creo que lo principal
es que hoy en día las relaciones son muy
desechables entonces a lo mejor este año
estoy celebrando san valentín con una
persona distinta al año siguiente porque
tenemos esta posibilidad de sentir que
siempre hay personas con las que podemos
construir esto no gracias a las
aplicaciones como team der etcétera que
nos dan esta sensación de que siempre va
a ver a alguien con quien podemos
reemplazar a la persona con la que
estamos actualmente entonces quizá es un
poco más efímero o más líquido todo
hablemos entonces también de la pandemia
y el amor qué efecto generó la pandemia
del cob y 19 en como nosotros nos
relacionamos afectivamente con las
personas y con nuestras parejas si ha
cambiado realmente la cosa o no mucho
pues creo que todavía estamos muy dentro
de la pandemia para saber realmente qué
efectos a largo plazo va a tener esto en
nuestras vidas afectivas amorosas pero
creo que muchas personas nos ha obligado
de alguna forma a poner encima de la
mesa de forma más explícita cuáles son
los acuerdos que tenemos con esos
vínculos si bien antes un espacio de
desencuentro en donde nuestras
necesidades no eran tan compatibles
podíamos evitarlo o evitar el conflicto
apartándonos pasando el día fuera de
casa sin sin tener que cohabitar tanto
el encierro la cuarentena de alguna
manera no se nos ha obligado primero yo
creo que poner sobre la mesa de forma
muchas más mucho más explícitamente
todos estos acuerdos y por otro lado
también a valorar más los vínculos
sociales quizá con las redes sociales
habíamos llegado a un punto en donde
parecía que
estábamos rodeados de gente sin
realmente estar y la pandemia a muchas
personas me imagino que les ha permitido
darse cuenta de lo importante que es
cuidar y cultivar todas sus relaciones
afectivas alva también los románticos
como yo hay muchísimas personas cuando
tenemos una pareja decimos que queremos
durar el resto de nuestra vida y pues
estamos en una relación como para ver
qué pasa y que perdure en el tiempo pero
qué recomendación es la mejor le puede
dar a esos románticos oa las personas
que también practican el poliamor que
están bien con sus parejas para poder
perdurar para poder llegar a que esa
relación nuestras relaciones duran
muchísimo tiempo o pues toda la vida
digamos
la regla de oro que esto viene del
instituto guttmann que lleva 25 años
investigando de forma cuantitativa las
relaciones amorosas
que tengamos momentos de encuentro en
una proporción 5 a 1 con los momentos de
ese encuentro es decir cada vez que
tengamos un conflicto un desaire alguna
situación incómoda dentro de la relación
que busquemos proactivamente
reencontrarnos y esto puede ser en
instancias chiquititas como preguntar
cómo estaba como ido tu día o darnos un
beso un abrazo antes de separarnos para
comenzar el día de trabajo decidir que
vamos a tener por lo menos una cita
semanal en donde pasamos tiempo de
calidad en fin cosas pequeñas que
permitan el encuentro de las dos
personas dentro de la relación para
contrarrestar esos momentos que de
desencuentro que en que tenemos y que es
normal tener en todos nuestros vínculos
y que siempre va a pasar al bayá para
finalizar rápidamente última reflexión
si debemos creer en el amor
esta es una pregunta muy complicada que
no puedo responder en este breve tiempo
que tenemos raúl
primero tendríamos que preguntarnos qué
es para nosotros el amor no entonces
creo que el amor está presente en muchas
de nuestras relaciones pero hay muchas
formas de entenderlo y creer en el amor
romántico ya es un paso más allá que
creer en el amor mismo bueno alva
muchísimas gracias entonces por su
tiempo por estar compartiendo este
espacio hablar del amor una palabra
complicada cuando se trata traslada a
las relaciones porque cada persona es un
mundo y cuando pues unes a una o más
pues ya tenemos muchos mundos pues ahí
compitiendo y no es tan fácil la cosa
pero pues creamos en el amor o seamos
románticos y creamos en él gracias salva
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa